but what negotiation is about is it's
about getting things done it's about
making decisions it's about changing
people's behavior it's about getting
more of what you want
what we do is we begin unpacking what
really is negotiation and in that
respect negotiation is problem-solving
so we then start from that and we begin
the process of how do you think about
negotiations what do you need to do you
first need to assess the situation is
this an opportunity for negotiation is
this an opportunity for me to get more
of what I want then I need to think
about preparation and we spend a lot of
time in the course thinking about how to
prepare and give you examples of good
and poor preparation but preparation is
not just about yourself it's about you
and your counterpart so how do I
understand what my counterpart wants and
when I put those two together I have a
really important insight into where the
negotiation could go in a way that makes
it better for me and better for my
counterpart and so now how do I start
the negotiation should I make the first
offer or should I wait and let my
counterpart make the first offer and
then what happens in the body of the
negotiation itself how can I exchange
information in a way that helps me
create as much value as possible but not
so much so that I handicap my ability to
claim value because at the end of the
day in negotiation your goal is to get a
good deal your goal is to get more of
what you want which means what do you
walk away with what do you claim
what we did was we tried to do something
creative and that creative thing turned
out to be with the help of an improv
troupe so we have a series of scenes in
the negotiation course illustrating
people's behavior and sometimes those
scenes illustrate bad behavior
negotiating badly sometimes the
negotiations are of people doing a good
job in their negotiations doing the
things we think lead to more effective
outcomes and sometimes we have a series
of stopgaps
will stop ask you what you think is
going to happen proceed ask you some
more questions so what we've done is
we've leveraged the creativity and the
innovation of this improv troupe to be
able to help us present to you the
important aspects of negotiation
my hope is is that once you're through
this course it will open your eyes to
the opportunities to negotiate that you
never even thought about and it will
give you the tools to be effective in
those negotiations